One last concept I'd like to discuss regarding indexes
is for using them for sorting.
So far we've been talking about using a hashtable
to create an index,
but one of the characteristics of a hashtable is that it's not sorted.
A hashtable is just a mapping of keys to values,
and if you remember how they're implemented,
they're implemented as a big array
with all these fields,
and inside these fields are these keys that
are basically the hashed version of sum value.
If you add a new element into your hashtable,
the new element can go into any one of these cells.
It could be the case that this key was added last.
It just happens that that key hashed to this position zero in the hashtable.
So we lose our sorting information when we use a hashtable.
And we saw some SQL queries before that used the order by statement.
Obviously that requires some sort of sorting.
So there's a different type of mapping we can use, and this is called a tree.
Trees are a basic data structure
that accomplish something similar to a hashtable,
but they have the nice property that they are sorted.
Why would you ever use a hashtable when you can use a tree instead?
Well, the downside is that the lookups are slower.
Hashtable's lookups are faster.
So I don't think we've talked about these algorithms yet in 101,
but basically a hash table has constant time lookup,
which means that generally looking up any particular key
in our hashtable is not a function of the number of keys in the hashtable.
Their inserting can be a little hazardous.
Remember those collisions. I think you talked about that in 101.
But in general, the lookups are going to be constant time.
And in a tree, the lookups are going to be roughly a function of log n,
where n is the number of elements in a tree.
So lookup speed decreases with
the size of the tree.
And depending on what you're going to use your index for,
you may choose to use a hashtable or a tree.
Many databases let you choose.
Some actually don't, or some choose for you.
Interesting property of indexes used by most relational databases
is that they preserve sorting,
and there's some cool things we can do with that.
One is that if you wanted to find all of the links in your database sorted by votes,
if you created an index on votes,
that would be a very, very fast query.
You would just go to the front of your tree--
your index on votes--and just read off the links.
And I'd like to show you how we use that at Reddit to make the hot algorithm work.